hi everyone my name is randy's at work
I'm thrilled to be here at this year's
World Economic Forum what's most
exciting to me is having worked in
social media for so many years I felt
like I had a real front-row seat to how
social media was being used to change
the world I saw firsthand response to
the disaster in Haiti Japan and all of
the events of the Arab Spring what
really excites me now is how to take all
of these influential voices online and
really coordinate them into one big
global broadcast system for good so
today I'm really excited to be working
hand in hand with the United Nations
yeah further progress the millennium
development goals especially around
another to child transmission is HIV and
we're putting together a thousand of the
most influential voices across Twitter
and Facebook and other social media
platforms in order to create more
awareness and distribution around us
important costs so thank you very much
and I hope that everyone that's
wonderful time